i'm i'm curious when you made your
previous you said that you didn't even
have a say in it did you get much say
when you're making this one like who you
wanted to bring on to it or was it
literally just find me two cute japanese
girls we had auditions
oh okay oh okay we held auditions and
yeah you got to choose
and yep so i was on the audition panel
tell you what auditioning is a totally
different thing as in
being on the choosing side of the
audition because for my whole life i've
been on the doing the auditions
right yeah it's the first time i've been
on the you know watching the audition
side
it's a different game yeah but instantly
it's um it's very interesting because it
kind of
takes away any it means that all the
times you've been rejected in auditions
it no longer feels personal once
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah push the panel
because you can see girls came in
and they were wonderful like they were
really good i was like i think you're
fantastic
but you're just not what we need right
now for this right
right right couple of them really good
but just
like a bit too tall things like this
right so but it's kind of upsetting
because you're like i want to give you a
job but i just can't
yeah right right so what were you
looking for what was the criteria
well not too tall that's it
not too tall that's it
really oh no no
[Laughter]
so were you like looking for like a
certain like vocal style because i
assume it's like
they had to be able to sing they had to
be able to dance they had to be small
enough they had to be
cute enough um they had to be willing to
normal idol
yeah yeah but they had to be willing to
go all over the world
because you know when there's no
freaking bloody
death flu apocalypse we're playing it
will be going all over the world
sound worse than it is death flu
apocalypse
that's a great artifact that's death
death for apocalypse is like
an amazing metal band named
that's what you should call baby beer
maybe i should yeah definitely that's
our second single death flu apocalypse
that's actually a really good idea
shiori make a note please
death flu apocalypse um i can't remember
what we were saying
the criteria
um like it's uh yes you had to be
willing to go overseas
and uh they were the main criteria and
then it's also
standing with me and the other two does
that
the people balance it out a lot of us
like you're really good
we really like you but you don't
fit together with me and any of the
other girls
who had to get two of them right right
one is relatively easy
two is hard right so you need two people
who can
match this up anyway we did uh we ended
up with two fantastic girls one called
kotomi and one called
suzu and foreigners always think suzu's
name is either susan or souza
it's neither of those two think suzuki
without the key
no you should just you should just
commit to the susan bit susan that
should be like her nickname
really yeah she's not a librarian
is every susan a librarian maybe they
are
i don't know a single susan single susan
i know you know a single susan you're a
single sisler
suddenly a single susan cannot be
established
in this or the seasons in the comments
section raise your hand right now
i'm a susan uh i am a big fan of susan's
everywhere
susans are wonderful people which
friendship what
i love you i'm not trying to offend you
the point i'm trying to make is
suzu is not named susan
that's the yeah but you made it sounded
like as if like i love everyone named
susan but these other names
yikes
so like okay so i guess like what did
you do
asking questions yeah right because it's
like [ __ ] is so crazy
yeah i have got the same musicians who
made nippon manju okay okay
and they have made a banger so nipple
monster is
like the famous that was the first that
was the famous lady babies
can i say the name of first single ah
please go to internets check out
me bye
it's amazing people it's piece of
musical madness
it'll make your earbuds tingle with
wonder you have never heard something as
amazing of this
adorable japanese cute little idol
voices
one noisy cross dresser screaming what
more could you want
in a musical product joey take us to a
commercial
our audio reader looks insane right now
you just destroyed